katia alors vous êtes devant le palais
bourbon quel est l'état d'esprit qui
règne parmi les protestataires cet après
midi vous a écouté ils viennent juste de
commencer leur rassemblement évidemment
il n'aura pas l'ampleur de ceux de ce
week-end comment vous vous parlait
d'ailleurs du trocadéro il a eu des
rassemblements dans une vingtaine de
villes est là aujourd'hui c'est un
rassemblement qui est majoritairement
composée de gilet jaune qui ont requis
ont d'ailleurs rejoint les
rassemblements de samedi
mais aujourd'hui bien sûr il y aura
moins d'affluence 1 mais en tout cas il
ya toujours cette opposition avec une
ferme détermination de faire échouer ce
projet qui menace les libertés de chacun
et notamment celle de notre profession
alors je suis d'ailleurs avec faouzi
lellouche est une figure bien connue des
jets les jeunes bons joueurs choisis
lellouche alors vous vous êtes mobilisés
plus que jamais sur sept ce projet
proposition de loi c'est évident pour
moi découle directement des deux années
de contestation sociale qu'il a pu y
avoir dans ce pays donc ça c'est une
réponse du gouvernement pour dire voilà
on va donner une certaine impunité on va
répondre favorablement aux syndicats et
aux fameux syndicat des commissaires
pour leur donner au moins quelque chose
et puis effacer ce qui est ce qui peut
être visible
concernant les bavures ou les violences
qui pourrait y avoir un futur
et voilà c'est un message qui est qui
qui n'est pas bon à nos yeux et qui est
dangereux parce que on pense vraiment
que cette loi
selon comment elle est interprétée dans
la rue par les policiers eux
peut déraper à tout moment on a pu le
voir mardi dernier où plusieurs
personnes ont été blessées plusieurs
journalistes aussi plusieurs
arrestations on a pu le voir samedi avec
aussi jusqu'à des journalistes qui ont
été menacés plusieurs ont été blessées
et crocheter on a pu voir une personne
qui aurait pu se fracasser la nuque par
terre on a pu voir aussi que cette nuit
avec ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
la course poursuite qui l'y a eu sur les
gens donc sans savoir que c'est des
journalistes ou pas le problème il est
pas là c'est un droit c'est une liberté
de pouvoir montrer ce qui se passe de
pouvoir témoigner et j'estime
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une entrave à nos
libertés c'est une entrave à la liberté
et ça permet normalement ces images de
pouvoir faire valoir ce qui se passe
pour ceux qui n'ont pas accès je pense
que voilà c'est un vrai recul dans notre
société pour nos libertés et pour la
démocratie étant donné que on a
l'impression que c'est
c'est cette loi personne peut l'arrêter
et c'est comme celle la loi
anti-casseurs la loi via bras c'est une
continuité de lois liberticides tout
simplement cela vous avez dit que
finalement c'est le mouvement des gilet
jaune qui d'une manière ou d'une autre a
donné naissance à cet article 24 ans
quoi comment vous avez déduit cela il a
suffi de voir les contestations les
dénonciations de violence et policière
qui a eu dans le pays pendant deux ans
toutes ces affaires qui en ont découlé
et justement aucune n'a été jugée
aucun blessé n'a obtenu réparation on a
eu énormément de personnes qui ont été
condamnées et là imaginez vous c'est à
l'appréciation de la police de décider
si s'il a envie de l'empêcher de filmer
ou pas et à un moment donné
ce n'est pas possible les images elles
sont bien faites là pour témoigner
quel autre choix il nous reste après vu
les dysfonctionnements qui peut y avoir
avec les lits gpn
donc on est obligé de le dénoncer et il
n'y a pas que ça c'est à dire qu'on a le
sentiment aussi que la loi allait déjà
en pratique parce que on a pu voir que
la semaine dernière et toute la semaine
les services de forces de l'ordre les
policiers ont déjà mis en application
ces lois oui alors justement est ce que
vous avez senti un changement d'ambiance
qui était déjà assez tendues avec les
manifestations des gilet jaune mais
depuis justement cette annonce de cette
loi comment est l'ambiance sur le
terrain ils font régner la peur en plus
de toutes la répression en plus delà de
cette politique de peur qu'il ya eu dans
le pays où on a pu constater énormément
de gens qui avait peur d'aller
manifester et bien qu'en plus ça on se
dit mais en plus il va pas falloir filmé
risque on risque de se faire arrêter
même s'il n'y a pas de condamnation
derrière vous savez vous faire arrêter
aller en garde à vue la façon de vous
êtes arrêté parce que ça peut être
violent c'est violent déjà
psychologiquement mais c'est aussi
violent physiquement donc pour reprendre
un petit peu les termes de de
l'invocation de leurs lois concernant
les images donc et puis je tiens à dire
aussi que nous on était moins que depuis
un an dans les manifestations leur
histoire de drones à l'est déjà en
pratique ça veut dire que quand il nous
demande à nous d'appliquer les règles et
d'être intolérant nous concernant eux
ils se permettent déjà d'appliquer des
règles qui font pas partie de la loire
le la diffusion est le fait de laisser
voler des drones dans l'air au dessus
des manifestations ça fait un an que ça
dure
pour preuve vendredi nous avions déclaré
ici une manifestation il y avait un
drone qui était au dessus de nous donc
ça veut dire qu'ils appliquent déjà des
choses qui ont même pas été validés ça
veut dire que vraiment c'est ccc pour
moi c'est ploie c'est de donner une
impunité et à la police et empêché que
la justice puisse être puisse se faire
valoir pour les personnes pour les
simples citoyens au caire c'est un
projet en effet que vous disais n'y a
pas que la question des vidéos mais
également la question des drones et
maints articles qui font des bas rhin
pas juste celui sur les vidéos
l'éventuelle floutage activement ils
font débat puis on
moi j'écoute un peu les propos qu'il y
avait à l'assemblée nationale sur les
délibérations sur les auditions j'ai le
sentiment que ils entendent ce que les
gens disent mais ils en font qu'à leur
tête qu'ils ont décidé de la date de la
mettre en pratique et qui aujourd'hui
peut empêcher aujourd'hui sincèrement
qu'ils ont peut empêcher la décision de
ces lois personnes j'aimerais juste vous
dire comme quoi que c'est pas qu'une
manifeste
son gilet jaune aujourd'hui on a fait un
appel général pour tous les gens qui
veulent nous rejoindre je sais qu'il ya
d'autres manifestations qui ont lieu
ailleurs
et comme samedi s'il ya des gens qui
veulent nous rejoindre c'est avec
plaisir parce que cette loi un concerne
tous les citoyens
merci faouzi lellouche merci pour vos
explications et nous suivons ici ce
rassemblement donc de gilet jaune à la
belgique ne met pas qu'avec des gilet
jaune puisque toute la société est censé
se joindre ainsi que des élus et nous
vous tiendrons au courant au fil de la
journée
merci beaucoup katia pique nique on va
donc vous retrouver dans le courant de
nos prochaines éditions enfin